In this lesson, we're going to take a look at
Lumen Visualizers,
and we're also going to look at some tips and tricks
to get you going in the right direction
when it comes to Lumen.
So let's get started.
The Lumen Visualizers allow us to actually see
what's being done and being calculated under the hood.
You also have under show,
the ability to turn off things
that are being calculated one by one,
not as a whole, as you would with the Lumen Visualizers.
The Lumen Visualizers give you an overview
of your old scene, your reflection, and your surface catch.
But under show, under Lumen,
we can actually pick walk through all the things
being calculated on a more distinct level
and turn them off.
Let's go and take a look at this briefly in Unreal
and to see how to access these.
To do so, we're going to go underneath lit,
first off, and go to Lumen
and look at the Lumen overview.
Again, these are the Lumen visualize mode.
I'll click on overview.
This is going to show me my geometry normals,
my hardware ray tracing hit lighting,
and my Lumen scene,
and it's showing pink missing surface catch coverage,
yellow called surface catch.
So basically it's giving me kind of my overall scene look
at what's being called
and what's being calculated to my liking.
Now, if you see, if you move away,
you'll see some yellow and some even pink in the distance
based on our angle and positioning.
As we get closer, you'll see some of those go away.
Now, some of these pieces,
when they're all one piece welded,
you will see some of those pink areas
for Unreal is trying to calculate them as best they can.
What you really want to avoid more than anything else
are black areas.
And that brings us to our next topic.
To be able to see those black areas,
we can use a Unreal visualize card placement number one
in our C-vars.
Now what this does overall,
what is happening is Lumen generates an automatic,
now it's a big word here,
para-materialization of the nearby scene surface
called a surface catch.
Used to quickly look up lighting
at ray hit points in the scene.
Lumen captures the material properties for each mesh
from multiple angles called cards
and are generated offline for each mesh.
So these cards can be seen and visualized ahead of time.
Now, if you get black areas on your mesh,
as you do this visualization,
that is telling you that those black areas
aren't being calculated correctly and there's an issue.
You'll see two different pieces here.
Here's one, which is a little bit more open
and may even be welded in this particular case.
But in this one, it's all one contained unit
to be able to walk through and have people interact with.
Unfortunately, Lumen doesn't really like that so much
because it's having a hard time calculating
where surfaces begin and end.
So it's better to be able to build your stuff
out of best practice on an individual basis
where you have a wall, make it very modulated,
build it like as if you're building a Lego set,
or you can think of it as in the real world,
how a house is actually built.
Now, a lot of times that that's a little bit better
and even in production workflows, that's better
because then you can customize each piece.
If you're using Houdini, you can use,
or even our geometry nodes,
or I should say procedural generated nodes.
You can actually use those in either case,
whether it's Houdini geometry nodes or in Unreal,
and you can build things on a practical basis
where it's individual pieces and change them on the fly.
So that's really a better method
when it comes to looking at things in Unreal.
Let's go into Unreal
and actually apply this visualization card placement
and take a look at how things are being calculated
on this dynamic level.
In Unreal, I'm gonna go to my output lock.
I'm gonna cheat a little bit.
I already have the visual card placement CVAR
already active and ready to go.
I'm gonna hit my, let me get rid of this one here.
I'm gonna hit my up arrow
and we'll see we have a Lumen visualize card placement at one.
Before we do that though,
let me make sure I put everything back to regular lit mode
just for safe precautionary measures there.
And I'm gonna go ahead and switch that card placement
to a one and hit enter.
Now Unreal is going to show me
how it is calculating these objects
and their surface information all at one time.
It seems to be doing a pretty good job.
This is built very modularly.
You'll see that there's pieces connected
and pushed into each other
as if it was built in the real world.
And I'm gonna go ahead and turn that off.
I'm gonna hit my up arrow, set that to zero
and hit enter.
And now we can see that it is turned off.
So the surface catch can be used to see areas
that don't have surface catch coverage.
They're colored pink in the surface catch view mode
of the level editor.
And you'll see these areas are in pink.
You'll notice so these areas will not bounce light
and will appear black in reflections.
So you gotta be careful with that.
So to be able to find those black areas
to make sure they do not become a problem,
you can use your visualizer to maybe spot them,
but also if you need to,
you can also increase the amount of mesh cards per task.
Now, again, the best practice as you see a note down here
is to separate your pieces as much as possible
and even modulate them because obviously
that'll make it a little bit less on the draw calls.
Does that mean you can't merge?
No, you can merge pieces,
but be aware of the issues that may occur.
So just be very smart and deterministic when you do so.
Only merge as needed, but at the same time,
there's also the ability to merge Nanite objects,
which we get into other classes using the merge tool.
Let's take a look here at some tips and tricks.
So Lumen reflections support more than one bounce
when hardware ray tracing is enabled with hit lighting.
So remember, it actually can help out a lot
if your card is able to do it.
And the max reflection bounces setting
in the post process file is set to two or greater.
So keep those things in mind
when you're actually using this particular feature.
This can prevent black areas and reflections
when there is enough performance budget to allow it.
So again, having a good card to be able to support this
is gonna be really key.
Lumen reflections can be used without Lumen GI,
so you can turn those on if you needed
for games and applications which use static lighting.
So just be very deterministic.
I always say, remember where you parked.
That means remember your settings.
So if you do mix and match your GI and your reflection,
say maybe you're using ray trace reflections,
you're using Lumen GI, you're using some other GI
and you're using Lumen reflections,
just remember where those settings lie
and what you have set in
so that you can troubleshoot things ahead of time.
So just be careful with that.
So Lumen hardware ray tracing optimizations,
you'll see including enabling async compute
for hardware ray tracing by default on console.
So this is in there for you to actually check things
and to make sure things are working correctly
when it comes to producing things for console.
Lumen overview visualization mode,
you'll see in 5.3 and includes the view of geometry
which we saw normals of the Lumen scene,
make it easier to spot issues with global distance fields
in the case of software ray tracing
or Nanite fallback meshes
in the case of hardware ray tracing.
So we've added that and it's very helpful for you.
You'll also see a CVAR here.
It says Lumen reflections and visualize traces
and is now added for visualizing
and debugging reflection rays.
So you can also use that CVAR too.
In 5.3 material AO updated,
we've now updated it so that previously
it was applied on top of the emissive and indirect lighting
but now you'll actually get a better result.
And you have to make sure your static
is lighting is turned off,
which we talked about previously,
because Lumen as you see at the very bottom
does not support static lighting.
Quick review for softening up those shadows.
We have source angle on a directional light
will soften your shadows,
your source radius on a local light
will soften your shadows.
So reminder about ray tracing mode.
This is going to be very beneficial for you
but you can choose this,
whatever your card can support.
If you're going to use a detailed tracing
or global tracing,
just be very deterministic when using it.
So that's about it with this one.
Here is some links to help you further your knowledge
on these topics.
And in the next video,
we're going to take a look at Nanite
in virtual shadow maps and how they work.
Thanks again.